y
[Música]
en israel convergen este lunes hechos
judiciales y políticos esta mañana se
reanudó el juicio del primer ministro
benjamin netanyahu por corrupción
mientras tanto el presidente rubén
rivlin mantiene consultas con los
representantes de los partidos para la
formación de un nuevo gobierno después
de las elecciones del 23 de marzo
tenemos análisis en esta emisión
en el estado de la florida en eeuu un
gigantesco embalse que contiene aguas
residuales de una antigua planta de
estos patos cerca de la ciudad de tampa
presenta a filtraciones y amenaza con
romperse el gobernador declaró el estado
de emergencia y ordenó la evacuación de
cientos de hogares
india reportó un aumento récord en los
casos de kobe 19 convirtiéndose en el
segundo país después de estados unidos
al registrar más de 100.000 en nuevos
casos en un día la nación es el mayor
fabricante de vacunas del mundo ha
inyectado a 77 millones de dosis sin
embargo sus vacunaciones per cápita son
más bajas que en otros países
muy buen día gracias por continuar con
nosotros en france 24 su revelan como
siempre un gusto saludarlos comenzamos
en israel donde hoy se unen los
acontecimientos judiciales y políticos
el primer ministro benjamin netanyahu
asistió a una audiencia judicial para la
reanudación de su juicio por varios
cargos incluido el de corrupción tuvo
que acudir a la corte donde se examinan
las pruebas y los testimonios asistió a
la declaración de apertura del fiscal y
como era de esperar abandonó la sala del
tribunal en reiteradas ocasiones ha
alegado que es una víctima de un intento
de golpe ante estos ciudadanos se
congregaron a las afueras del tribunal
para manifestarse a favor y en contra
del mandatario también hoy iniciaron las
consultas por parte del presidente rubén
rivlin para formar un gobierno de
coalición luego de las elecciones del 23
de marzo las cuartas en dos años en las
que netanyahu busca mantenerse en el
poder
vamos ahora hasta jerusalén donde se
encuentra nuestro invitado gabriel
ventas cal analista político
especializado en medio oriente gabriel
gracias por estar aquí nuevamente con
nosotros en france 24 hablemos primero
de los casos contra el primer ministro
netanyahu estos procesos judiciales
podrían tardar años además el mandatario
no está obligado a renunciar le pregunto
cuáles serían entonces los escenarios
posibles para netanyahu
bueno puede llegar a ser incluso raúl
que no se llega al final del juicio
puede ocurrir que debido a los problemas
políticos de netania aún no logre formar
gobierno y su partido decida
reemplazarlo por otro líder y por ende
llegue a algún tipo de acuerdo con la
fiscalía y no se concluya sino en una
especie de acuerdo nada más osea ese es
un primer escenario metan ya no quiere
ir hasta el final porque argumenta que
no hay realmente carne para acusarlo y
sentenciarlo digamos que quería quiere
ir entonces al final para demostrar su
inocencia entonces ahora le pregunto ay
qué manera esto del juicio ha afectado a
netanyahu y al partido likud en las
últimas cuatro elecciones el
estancamiento para formar un gobierno de
coalición se podría deber a esto
muchísimo le ha afectado porque hay una
cantidad de partidos políticos que
argumentan que no se pueden sentar en un
gobierno de coalición con una persona
que está en proceso judicial tengamos en
cuenta aquí se habla mucho de la ley
francesa se habla que el primer ministro
debía poder gozar de una especie de
inmunidad hasta que termine su cadencia
por el momento no existe tal cosa aquí
por lo tanto no ha pasado nunca que un
primer ministro esté en proceso judicial
durante sus funciones ahora gabriel en
ese sentido el presidente israelí está
en ese momento en consulta con varios
partidos para ver posibles alianzas y
coaliciones gobernantes cuál es la que
más se perfila para gobernar
es muy complicado decirlo porque tenemos
tres escenarios el más probable y es que
los partidos que no están a favor de
metal ya o logren algún tipo de acuerdo
de rotación
y logren conformar gobierno igual no es
una gran probabilidad la segunda que
letanía aun logre conformar un gobierno
sólido con la ortodoxia judía y con el
apoyo compartido árabe desde afuera del
gobierno y la tercera y creo yo que es
la más probable es que vayamos a una
quinta elección eso le quería decir de
no llegar entonces a ninguna alianza
gobernante podríamos estar entonces como
usted lo dice a las puertas de unas
quintas elecciones y hasta cuándo
podemos ver entonces este estancamiento
de la formación de un ejecutivo
la bolsa es cuál es el chiste más famoso
en estos días es que las próximas
elecciones y es que regresamos entonces
ya van a colocar dos urnas para que ya
pongas tu voto por la quinta elección y
por la sexta elección
gabriel entonces esperemos a ver qué
pasa si estamos a las cuerdas con usted
lo dice de unas quintas elecciones y
también posiblemente de unas ex agracias
por estar aquí con nosotros en france 24
que tenga usted un feliz resto día en
jerusalén cambiamos de información en
eeuu un embalse de aguas contaminadas
amenaza con romperse cerca de la ciudad
de tampa florida los equipos de
emergencia del estado están trabajando a
contrarreloj evacuando a millones de
galones de agua para tratar de evitar lo
que podría convertirse en una catástrofe
medioambiental el gobernador de florida
ron de santis declaró estado de
emergencia y ordenó evacuar a la gente
del área aunque muchos creen que nuestra
razón suficiente para abandonar sus
hogares y han decidido quedarse alva
santana tiene el informe
es un peligro inminente un enorme
embalse de aguas residuales
amenaza con romperse en la localidad de
paine y point cerca de la ciudad de
tampa tras la detección de grietas en la
estructura los equipos de emergencia
trabajan a contrarreloj intentando
evitar una catástrofe medioambiental en
la bahía el gobernador del estado ron de
santis declaró estado de emergencia el
sábado y pidió responsabilidades a la
empresa hr k propietaria del embalse lo
que estamos viendo ahora es para tratar
de prevenir y responder si es necesario
a una situación de inundación
catastrófica real también quiero ser
claro si bien nuestra principal
preocupación es garantizar la seguridad
de la comunidad nuestra administración
está dedicada a hacer cumplir por
completo cualquier daño a los recursos
de nuestro estado y responsabilizar a la
empresa hr camps porque este evento se
estima que la balsa contiene unos 480
millones de galones de agua mucha de
ella usada en el procesado de fosfatos
sin embargo un colapso del depósito
podría hacer que el yeso fosforado
y radioactivo para la producción de
fertilizantes almacenado en la zona se
ha arrastrado y con también el
ecosistema
por ello el condado manatí ordenó la
evacuación de más de 300 casas de la
zona aunque muchos no creen que sea
razón suficiente para abandonar sus
domicilios descarta este terreno es un
poco más alto que el de otras áreas así
que preferimos quedarnos aquí y bng ni
con los huracanes y todo no evacuamos
aquí de momento los trabajadores de
emergencia desplegados están descargando
33 millones de galones de agua al día
para frenar una inundación con aguas
tóxicas a este ritmo tomaría entre 10 y
12 días completar la operación de manera
segura vamos ahora está indicando éste
reportó un aumento récord en los casos
diarios de coke 19 al registrar más de
100.000 según las estimaciones los
contagios diarios del país se han
multiplicado por 12 desde que alcanzaron
un mínimo de varios meses a principios
de febrero cuando las autoridades
aliviaron la mayoría de
restricciones con 103 mil 558 nuevos
casos india ha reportado 12 puntos 6
millones de positivos el más alto
después de eeuu y brasil
las muertes ascienden a 165 mil 101
y es que las ciudades más grandes de
india implementaron confinamientos más
estrictos y otras restricciones en un
nuevo intento por frenar las cifras de
estos contagios la más alta en seis
meses india continúa siendo el tercer
país del mundo más afectado por la
pandemia
este fin de semana india rompió el
récord de contagios diarios superando
las cifras registradas en septiembre del
año pasado el estado de maharashtra en
el occidente del país es una de las
regiones más golpeadas cuenta con más de
la mitad del total de casos que tiene
esa nación el estado ordenó cerrar todos
los bares restaurantes lugares de culto
y centros comerciales además de una
cuarentena total los fines de semana las
nuevas medidas entran en vigor este
lunes tenemos que tomarnos esto muy en
serio y ser extremadamente cuidadosos
los casos de covite están aumentando
rápidamente tenemos que mantenernos a
salvo continuar con las medidas de
licenciamiento que ha tomado el gobierno
nacional
entre tanto el gobierno indio ha
intensificado su campaña de vacunación
en las últimas semanas pero el proceso
ha sido lento en una nación de más de
1300 millones de personas
todos deberían recordar lo rápido que
han aumentado los casos en el país y
vacunarse para salvar sus vidas hasta
que un día solo está por debajo de eeuu
y brasil en número de casos con más de
12 millones registrados desde el inicio
de la pandemia a continuación los invito
a que repasemos las noticias destacadas
de la pandemia en américa latina las
principales ciudades de colombia
comienzan desde este lunes y hasta el 19
de abril un nuevo ciclo de restricciones
para enfrentar el tercer pico de la
pandemia después de que miles de
personas viajaron en semana santa los
mandatarios locales deberán omitir los
decretos con toques de queda y también
restricciones de actividades dependiendo
de la ocupación de las unidades de
cuidados intensivos
pasamos a brasil país que roza los 13
millones de casos de kobe 19 y enfrenta
el peor momento de la pandemia este
domingo el país se registró 30 en mil
359 contagios en las últimas 24 horas
descendieron las muertes diarias a 1.240
pero las autoridades han reiterado que
las cifras suelen ser más bajas fines de
semana debido a la falta personal para
registrar los datos
y venezuela registró en las últimas 24
horas mil 786 casos de kobe 19 lo que
supone el número más alto hasta el
momento y cerró la peor semana de la
pandemia en el país así lo informó la
vicepresidenta ejecutiva de si rodríguez
desde el comienzo de la pandemia en el
país 164 mil 516 personas se han
contagiado de al menos mil 644 han
muerto
y cambiamos ahora nuevamente de
información vamos hasta jordania donde
los conflictos dentro del palacio
avecinan una de las mayores crisis en el
reinado de abdalá segundo su medio
hermano el príncipe hamza bin husein es
acusado de complot para socavar la
seguridad del país hamza rechaza estos
señalamientos por ahora las autoridades
continúan las investigaciones y
mantienen las acusaciones contra el
príncipe al menos 16 personas han sido
arrestadas acusadas de sedición y
también amenazar la seguridad del reino
acusaciones contra el ex príncipe
heredero de un complot malicioso
destinado a desestabilizar el reino con
el apoyo de entidades extranjeras las
autoridades jordanas aseguran que el
príncipe hans a medio hermano del rey
abdalá ha estado buscando el apoyo de
líderes tribales en contra del gobierno
y las notas que hat la abuela en las
investigaciones iniciales han revelado
que personas cercanas al príncipe hamza
han pasado alegaciones y cartas a
partidos extranjeros incluida las llama
posición extranjera para instarlos a
trabajar contra la seguridad nacional y
distorsionar los hechos
huila con el ministro de exteriores
anunció que al menos otras 16 personas
han sido arrestadas acusadas de amenazar
la seguridad nacional anteriormente el
presidente del senado jordano dijo que
nadie está por encima de la ley
organiza siempre en el punto de mira
históricamente lo están
hay partidos extranjeros en el juego
agitando la estabilidad pero este es un
país muy arraigado jordán es un país muy
arraigado y consistente bajo el mandato
de su majestad el región
el sábado el príncipe hans ha difundido
un vídeo acusando a los gobernantes
jordanos de nepotismo y corrupción y a
los servicios de seguridad de abusos por
criticar todos estos aspectos